une minute de silence pour commencer
cette réunion un hommage aux attentats
survenus à bruxelles mardi 22 mars avant
de laisser place aux échanges concernant
le budget 2016 de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines premier vote
avec les douze communes dans un contexte
compliqué de baisse des dotations de
l'état
nous avons encore dû trouver près de 6
millions d'économies alors de l'avons
fait sans aucun problème avec
enthousiasme aussi parce que un ou ce
qui nous tient à coeur c'est de servir
les habitants de cinq ans david et les
entreprises dont première chose de
l'avons fait sans augmenter les impôts
donc aujourd'hui pas d'impôts sur les
ménages pas d'abo sur les entreprises
adoptées à 47 voix contre 24 le budget
principal donne la priorité au
développement économique la politique de
désendettement se poursuit et plus de 72
millions d'euros seront alloués à
l'investissement il n'y a pas de
d'orientation de 2 définit il y a eu des
baisses dans des domaines qui peuvent
toucher très directement les habitants
de saint quentin en yvelines
je pense aux associations je pense au
social je pense également à la culture
comme d'ailleurs l'année dernière et
donc que moi ce que je dirais c'est que
ce budget qui aurait dû être un budget
collectif un budget pour préparer
l'avenir est devenu finalement un budget
pour lui d'être 12 ans n'était 12 -
quatre communes totalement mis de côté
un budget de transition car les cinq
nouvelles communes de l'agglomération
sont intégrés dans ce budget à titre
prévisionnel
jusqu'à présent les communes gardent
entièrement leurs recettes
donc c'est tout le travail qui sera fait
au cours de cette année 2016 définir les
compétences et surtout le périmètre des
différentes compétences et c'est là
qu'on va savoir ce que nous allons
garder ce que nous allons diminuer qui
va nous permettre ensuite à travers des
transferts financiers des communes vers
l'agglomération ou de l'agglomération
vers les communes de pouvoir enfin pour
l'année 2010 m
avoir un vrai budget à 12 pour un budget
à 12 il faudra donc attendre 2017 à
saint quentin en yvelines